donner la parole de notre colère de
Bernard delcro pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
il avait la parole
chers collègue tout au long de l'examen
de ce projet de loi de finance pour 2023
notre groupe a eu à cœur de suivre une
ligne qui nous semble clair et cohérente
guidé par deux constantes d'une part
veiller à contenir notre déficit et
notre endettement bien sûr en limitant
autant que possible les dépenses de
l'État mais aussi en agissant sur le
levier des recettes parce que nous
sommes convaincus que nous ne réussirons
pas à redresser nos comptes publics sans
accroître nos recettes
deuxième constante l'équité fiscale
sociale et territorial et l'équité ce
n'est pas l'égalité de traitement
c'est au regard de cette ligne que nous
avons défendu la contribution
exceptionnelle de solidarité sur les
super profits et l'argile au-delà du sel
secteur de l'énergie un amendement
soutenu par notre collègue Sylvie
vermeiller cette mesure aurait
pré-permie en premier lieu de compenser
pour partie les dépenses exceptionnelles
que portent ce budget et que nous
soutenons par ailleurs pour protéger les
Français les entreprises les
collectivités face à la hausse des prix
notamment ceux de l'énergie en second
lieu un moment où on demande beaucoup
aux Français comment expliquer que les
très très grandes entreprises les plus
grandes entreprises qui accumulent des
profits records parfois en raison de la
crise actuelle ne contribue pas
davantage à la solidarité nationale à
dépenses exceptionnelles mesure
exceptionnelles
c'est aussi
pour ne pas priver l'état de 4 milliards
d'euros de recettes cette année et 8
milliards l'année prochaine que nous
avons défendu le report de la
suppression de la CVAE cette suppression
ne nous paraît pas opportunes au moment
où tant de dépenses sont nécessaires
pour faire face à la crise et que deux
surcroît les données macroéconomiques
sur lesquelles est fondée ce budget sont
fragiles au regard des incertitudes qui
pèsent sur le contexte européen et
mondial
par ailleurs nous nous réjouissons que
le Sénat nous est suivi sur la
suppression de plusieurs niches fiscales
un sujet cher à notre collègue Michel
canvett dans un double objectif
d'efficacité budgétaire et de justice
fiscale parmi elles la suppression d'une
niche implicite sur la transmission du
patrimoine des plus fortunés qui
contournent l'impôt sur le revenu en
exploitant une faille du dispositif
nouveau des PER une anomalie qui
coûterait plusieurs milliards d'euros à
l'État selon certaines estimations
ainsi plusieurs mesures souvent de
justice fiscale adoptés par le Sénat en
première partie ont permis de réduire
notre déficit de 6,9 milliards et sans
doute davantage parce qu'un certain
nombre de mesures n'ont plus être
chiffrées par vos services sur le volet
budgétaire le projet de loi de finance
pour 2023 poursuit sa stratégie de
hausse des budgets de plusieurs
ministères régaliens la justice la santé
l'enseignement la sécurité la défense
nous considérons que ces hausses sont
nécessaires pour permettre à ces
ministères de mener à bien leur mission
qui sont essentielles pour le pays
concernant les collectivités locales sur
la DGF notre groupe n'était pas
favorable à une réponse uniforme pour
toutes les collectivités parce que nous
savons bien que derrière les moyennes
parfois flatteuses se cachent de fortes
disparité aussi pour tenir compte de
cette réalité et par ces mesures
d'équité nous soutenions le choix
d'augmenter la DGF en ciblant les
collectivités les plus fragiles nous
avons eu un long débat monsieur le
ministre sur la réforme des critères de
répartition de la DSR et des voix se
sont élevées sur tous les bandes pour
que les critères de la longueur de
voirie communale soit maintenue sa
suppression pénaliserait les plus
petites communes nous comptons sur vous
monsieur le ministre pour entendre cette
voix une année du Sénat
concernant la dotation aux communes pour
la protection de la biodiversité et la
valorisation des aminés rurales le Sénat
a renforcé les moyens qui lui sont
consacrés pour une meilleure
reconnaissance de l'apport de la
ruralité à la préservation de notre
environnement
c'est un message positif adressé aux
maires des campagnes de France et nous
souhaitons vivement que dans le texte
final le gouvernement conserve cette
belle avancée en matière
d'investissement le nouveau fond vert
voté doté de 2 milliards d'euros dont la
gestion sera confiée au préfet de
département et nous soutenons cette idée
viendra compléter
utilement la DETR et la décile pour
soutenir les investissements des
collectivités locales enfin le Sénat a
adopté la réintégration des dépenses
d'aménagement de terrain dans
l'éligibilité au FCTVA une mesure vous
le savez très attendu des cellules
locaux
je veux pour terminer évoquer les
mesures visant à protéger les
collectivités les ménages et les
entreprises face à l'explosion du coup
de l'énergie
nous soutenons le plafonnement de la
hausse des tarifs réglementés en faveur
des ménages et des petites collectivités
ainsi que l'amortisseur électricité en
faveur des collectivités et des
entreprises qui nous semblent bien
ciblées et mieux calibrer à 180 euros le
mégawattheure plutôt qu'à 325 comme
prévu initialement nous voulons saluer
cette avancée nous avons aussi soutenu
l'amendement du Gouvernement voté par le
Sénat vendredi pour élargir les
ligibilité au bouclier tarifaires gaz
électricité notamment en faveur des
EHPAD et des résidences autonomiques en
revanche le Sénat a revu les critères
d'éligibilité aux filets de sécurité
énergie en faveur des collectivités pour
le rendre plus simple plus claire plus
efficace il nous semble important que
vous conserviez au final un dispositif
simplifié et suffisamment ouvert
monsieur le ministre au terme de ces
semaines de débat notre groupe tient
d'abord à vous remercier pour votre
présence continue votre écoute et la
facilité de nos échanges même si nous
aurions souhaité parfois davantage
d'ouverture vers les propositions du
Sénat notre groupe de l'Union centriste
à la quasi uneanimité votre rat le
projet de budget
issu des débats du Sénat
merci mon cher collègue
de donner la parole
notre collègue